moving to this from the daily wire the
first Indiana Jones movie Raiders of the
Lost Ark came out in 1981 back then
Harrison Ford was 38. now Ford's 80
years old not exactly the age of an
action hero and the fifth installment of
the movie is not faring well with
critics uh Peter Howell the Toronto Star
wrote quote it's all pretty goofy and
laborious over its 142 minute running
time 142 minutes
the Rolling Stone review was even more
harsh you either die as an intellectual
property hero trapped in Amber or you
live long enough to see yourself riding
a fake horse against a green screen
Subway background when most of your
peers have slowed down
critic David fear wrote quote you're
largely left with what you'd imagine
you'd get if you programmed a 21st
century AI program to write up Nostalgia
bait for the children of the late 20th
century
um so a lot of a lot of reviews like
this
um
with a running time of nearly two and a
half hours reviewers said the 300
million dollar movie is a bloated mess
with endless Chase scenes David Rooney
The Hollywood Reporter wrote quote that
non-stop pacing might sound ideal but
it's mostly an exhausting slog
and so much phony CGI quote parts of
what dims the enjoyment of this
concluding chapter is just how glaringly
fake so much of it looks Rooney wrote
maybe the filmmaker should have stopped
at four installments while some
reviewers said Ford still has his
trademark Swagger One reviewer wrote
quote I'm not sure how many fans want to
see Indiana Jones as a broken helpless
old man who cowers in the corner while
his patronizing God goddaughter takes
the lead but that's what we're given and
it's as Bleak as it sounds
so that's um Indiana Jones
five for you an 80 year old daughtering
incompetent Indiana Jones
being lectured to by his uh woke
goddaughter
that sound appealing is that everybody
on board for that
honestly and not to put too fine a point
on it or make too much of it but
if this movie doesn't absolutely bomb
at the box office then I think I I give
up on America I I give up like I give up
on this country if this movie does not
completely tank did you know our friends
at genucel have upgraded their most
popular package to feature their top
selling deep firming vitamin C serum
plus Ultra retinal moisturizer with
natural retinal alternative right now
you can take advantage of this limited
time package upgrade for 70 off why
waste time and money to go get work done
on your face when you can get genucel
skin care shipped right to your door
gender cell secret is a family recipe
for over 20 years that makes it safe for
all skin types and perfect for both men
and women made by a compounding
pharmacist and small batches and always
safe cruelty free and natural you know
my marketing manager loves genucel's
under eye bag cream she said she cannot
go a day without it uh
we're just gonna move past that so
there's not a whole thing where I'm
making fun of her and saying how ugly
and hit-ish is really is she it's okay
anyway
a hideous Beast that is now slightly
less ugly because of Jenny cell go to
genucel.com and I have to have to make
it up on my own is what we're left with
go to genyourself.com Welsh YT and try
Jenny cell's most popular package for 70
off featuring both genu sales Ultra
retinal and genucel's Firming Serum get
a complimentary Spa Essentials box with
every package order plus free upgrade to
priority priority shipping that's
genusol.com Walsh YT genucel.com
if this is not a humiliating box office
disaster that ends the careers of
everybody involved
then I give up I mean the country is
done there's like seriously this is a
hollow lifeless cash grab remake that
has none of the original the the charm
of the Original Series has no respect
for the characters has no respect for
the audience
is being used as a vehicle to send yet
another message about how men are stupid
and useless
there's just no reason to watch it like
why would you watch it
there's no possible incentive
if audiences go to watch it then it will
simply be because of
zombie-like instincts to mindlessly
consume whatever garbage these movies
Studios dump on our heads and if that
instinct is so overwhelming
that even this movie does well at the
box office then yeah I don't know
I think there's no hope because we don't
have
there's not enough mind left okay we're
not we're not thinking enough anymore
especially after all like everybody
complains and rightly so
about
the the cash grab remakes and sequels we
complained about that for decades
everyone knows they're never good
and then there's the and there's the
wokeness factor too being preached to
constantly
everyone complains about it and then
these movies come out and many of these
same people still go and they spend lots
of money to watch the movies
and if that if we have that little
self-control then uh then what hope is
there so yes that is if if this is not a
box office bomb then America's
officially doomed it's it is all over
that's what I'm saying that'll do it for
this portion of shows and move over to
the members block you become a member
today by using Code walls to check out
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed